let's jump into this talk about the
election what's going on because we got
some we got a couple bits of breaking
news
the first is that georgia recount
unearths more than 2
600 uncounted ballots in floyd county
and it gave a net gain of 800 votes
to donald trump it still leaves biden in
the leap this is one county
i'm not sure these kind of changes are
going to be enough to push trump over
the edge it's one county again 800 votes
maybe maybe there's something going on
we had a story this is
this is really crazy out of i think it
was new hampshire where they did a hand
recount
and found a five to six percent bump for
the republicans
the democrats point five percent one guy
got
minus two how does that happen like what
they were saying was
when they when they when they started
hand recounting the machine didn't scan
some of these ballots and so they're
like okay that makes sense just so
happened that there were 10 times more
republican than democrat
and somehow a democrat the machine
scanned more votes for the democrat when
they weren't for the democrat
why is it always going in one direction
right that's what's getting weird
but apparently i saw someone in the chat
say this trump tweeted something out
adam paul looks all let's see did you
tell us who this guy is he's uh just a
verified twitter user said
the clark county commission just threw
out an election that represents almost
one-sixth of the total votes cast
in clark county because there were too
many discrepancies
to be sure that the results in that
election can be certain 153 000 votes in
this election
so i'm not sure if that's the
presidential one or what that is but uh
trump says
big victory moments ago in the state of
nevada the all-democrat county
commissioner race
on the same ballot as president just
thrown out
because of large-scale voter discrepancy
clark county officials do
not have confidence in their own
election security
this is crazy they look at megan
messerly says
clark county register joe gloria on the
clark county commission district c
race quote we have found discrepancies
that we
can't explain that would cast a doubt on
whether or not that margin of victory is
solid
if that's on the same ballot if that's
in the same ballot for president
what about all those votes you can't
just say one of the votes didn't make
sense the bouts themselves are in
question
so so what can i just check with you if
i did the math correctly and
it turns out that all of these ballots
are wrong and they're 5.6
in trump's favor would that not be like
a massive victory for him yes
okay if if what we see in this this new
hampshire race where the republicans got
a big boost around five percent
it was only several hundred votes
because it was you know very small uh
you know small areas small communities
relatively small
but if that translate even even half if
trump got two percent
across the board on average oh landslide
easily he'd win like
a ton of states he'd win all the swing
states in my book about 2016 election i
interviewed somebody who worked as
a she was in the democratic party at the
time and she caucused for bernie
and she described to me all of the
nonsense that went on in clark county
clark county
is like gangster central when it comes
to elections dude like bernie's office
got shot up that year
what yeah there was riot there was burn
yeah look it up bernie's office
jamie fact check me yeah yeah bernie
bernie's
office got shot up in 2016 in clark
county
there was basically like a riot on the
floor of the state level caucus for
president
they think they those folks claimed that
they like shut down all the parking lots
in the whole area they wouldn't let
casino workers off work that day so they
could go caucus
they made it very difficult they changed
the rules of the caucus on the floor
with like
there was all kinds of things that went
on clark county they hustle
to get the votes that they want right
they really do
clark county's actually you know las
vegas was was seated by people from the
east
right like casinos and gangsters and
stuff so no shocker there
really it's just like east coast
corruption exported out to the west
yeah and that's voter suppression and
then then we got sydney powell coming in
hard with dominion
uh which would be considered i guess
you'd call that fraud so there's like
suppression
fraud there's discrepancy democrats
actually wrote a letter
to dominion in december of 2019
concerned about
the potential for voter fraud notably
switching votes
so this has long been known about the
democrats were actually setting it up to
challenge it if they lost
now that it's looking like joe biden
they're mum's the word not gonna say
anything was it was it just a meme that
i saw but it was just like a fake
dominion logo
because okay that was fake yeah it was
hysterical it said like dominion
changing the way people vote or
something like that
and then there was like red ones going
in and blue ones coming out
changing the way it looked like it could
have been the legit logo it was really
funny
i had to look it up because i was like
this can't be real it's only the red one
going in there's not a blue one coming
out so so check this out trump is
tweeting about clark county
they're saying there's 153 000 votes in
this
in this county as a democrat county
right is that what you're saying uh you
know i don't know but i i think it is
i think trump was saying that right we
just know we just read it i mean so if
they throw this out it's going to be
trump wins nevada that would be amazing
but what they're saying is so i've got
this
this tweet thread from megan messerly
she is
uh the envy india reporter she says
clark county registrar joe gloria notes
that the only race
they have an issue with is the
commission district c race because of
the 10 vote margin
that's the only race in the entire
election we have any concern related to
the outcome
and it's because of the margin clark
county commissioner
segerblom is pressing the point that if
there is a recount the same
discrepancies would still be present a
recount does not address those
discrepancies
they're not discussing the fact that
clark county could set up a
special election for just one particular
race
to re-run the election if it doesn't
certify the results it sounds like there
are essentially two routes
either the clark county commission could
make a decision on the re-vote today
or they could certify the results of the
election
stavros anthony takes the matter to
court and a court could order a re-vote
clark county registrar joe gloria says
there is no election that goes without
identified discrepancies the issue here
is the margin of victory
gloria says they go through to ensure
the discrepancies are smaller than the
margin of victory which isn't true in
this case
clark county commissioner larry brown is
now amending his motion
asking the clark county register to come
back at their first meeting in december
with options for a special election in
the race gloria says the cost of a
special election depends on how the
election is held
yada yada then they say clark county
commissioner uh commission chair
malen marilyn kirkpatrick
what is going to happen to the people
who voted twice i hope that we're going
to go after them she says
gloria says the cases will be referred
to the sos for investigation
people voted twice she's saying that
people voted twice
okay then why would it only be an issue
with one race
is there is there is there something i'm
missing i think i think what
who's that insane man trump said trump
said this right
that's uh on the same ballot as the
president
100 and this guy adam paul laxalt says
153 000 votes in this election
how can they keep any of those ballots
if one of those races gets thrown out
that's got to be grounds for for a legal
team to be like dude no way
if they're saying they're throwing out
one race because of dupe like someone
voted twice
the whole thing's got to be dirty what
do you do do you re-vote nevada can't be
certified
there's a lot of smoke there's a lot of
smoke there's a lot of smoke but you
know what's funny
i mean and not to put a wet blanket on
any of this if you do i just gotta stop
you real quick
twitter didn't flag trump's tweet what
this tweet from trump is not flagged
whoa yup just below it trump says let's
not fall into that trap
let's not fall into that trap i don't
want to though of this of letting
twitter
it's nice to inform
the issue is twitter is willing to flag
any and everything true but they
couldn't do this one right
because this one's legitimately true
yeah so so let's listen listen here's
what i'm saying and the new hampshire
one two was it twitter
twitter's at the standard if twitter
wants to be the arbiter of truth here
well okay twitter you got me you're the
one who gets the flag misinformation
this one's not flagged it must be true
boom done end of story that is true yeah
everybody wants to play
every election there's stuff like this
going on and if you took a deep look you
would find discrepancies and double
countings and bet mail and ballot fraud
and all kinds of stuff in every election
that ever happened
ever that being said this is the one
that really matters to me so i say we
think you can really
do but this would flip nevada for trump
i would say so it's still not enough
trump needs three states
i'm you know what's really funny man i
don't know if you guys see the jesse
waters
segment he did on the election he says
it something doesn't feel right
biden wasn't campaigning he was hiding
in the basement calling lids for
for a week disappearing and all of a
sudden now he's
up something doesn't feel right the
biggest vote total
in the history of more than all the time
more
this is something i do not understand
like why how did he do nothing and then
come out the only thing that i could
maybe add to him just from being on the
ground is
before the george floyd situation
happened when i would interview
uh people on the left you know obviously
a lot of people are bernie supporters
bernie voters when i would say hey would
you be voting for biden
in this upcoming election they would all
say absolutely not we're going to either
hold our vote
kind of like the way they did in 2016
yeah then as soon as the george floyd
thing happened
all these progressives said we're
basically just gonna be voting for biden
because he's not trump so
i'm not saying that one reason went over
70 but i think one thing that wasn't
talked about on mainstream news and i
think
you can't really pull it was there was a
black lives matter vote
there was there were people that
literally voted off just that issue
nothing else black lives matter net
support is lower now than it was last
year
according to civics polling of hundreds
of thousands of people found
that just before the george floyd
incident their net support was around
like 10 or so percent
meaning like compared to opposition so
all in all it was i think the total
support
in the country was just under like it
was like 40 or so percent or something
like that
or no i think it was like 47 it
skyrocketed after george floyd
and then plummeted riots so their net
support has actually
dropped so i'm not i'm not it dropped
almost like 10 points just in
uh the state of uh wisconsin with the
whole kenosha situation so i'm i'm
not convinced that was uh the driver but
i do think it's fair to say
people don't like trump there's a lot of
people who don't like the guy and i talk
to my friends and they don't know
anything about politics
but they know everything about pop
culture so they're like
i just don't like this man the only
thing they know is you know kim
kardashian
sold something and they know like kanye
wanted to run for president and then
they heard about trump and said trump is
bad
and so they go and vote they go and vote
they never watch the apprentice
no i guess not thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you